[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter's mother
lily and harry's godfather sirius black
more specifically we're going to be
taking a look at a secret letter that
lily wrote to sirius in the year 1981
shortly after harry potter was born
harry potter was of course born to
parents james potter
and lily evans the story of their love
was an interesting one
as when they first met lilly wasn't too
impressed by james
lilly had grown up in the town of coke
worth and spent much of her youth with
her childhood companion
severus snape who grew up in nearby
spinner's end
when lily and snape began attending
hogwarts james potter was horrible to
snape
which negatively skewed lily's
perception of james
however when snape eventually began to
go down a very dark and troubled path
a path involving dark magic and terrible
people things changed
one day while snape was being bullied by
james lilly intervened
the embarrassed snape then lashed out at
lily calling her
a filthy mudblood this effectively ended
their relationship
while james was at school he was part of
a quartet of boys that called themselves
the marauders
the boys began their studies in 1971 the
same year as severus snape
and they all had one thing in common
they were all gryffindors
before the sorting ceremony even
happened the boys hit it off
and when they were eventually sorted
into the same house they knew that they
were destined to be friends
though the boys got on with many of
their other classmates this particular
group of four boys
had a truly special bond this group was
comprised of james potter
remus lupin peter pettigrew and the
subject of this video
sirius black sirius was a great friend
of the potters
so much so that he was chosen to be the
godfather of harry potter
sirius hailed from the powerful
wizarding family the blacks
and while many of his family members
placed an unreasonable amount of value
on blood purity sirius did not share
this same belief
many of the members of the black family
went down a very dark path
but sirius was able to choose his own
path after graduating
sirius along with the other marauders
went on to join the order of the phoenix
the purpose of the order was to oppose
lord voldemort and the death eaters
however it turned out that not all
members of the order were good
as sirius's old friend peter pettigrew
would go on to frame sirius for a
heinous crime
in 1981 just one day after the potters
were murdered
peter pettigrew murdered 12 muggles
using a dark and powerful blasting curse
some way somehow serious black was
blamed and was promptly sent to azkaban
after being banished to azkaban seeming
the whole world turned on sirius
and he was left there to rot for
astonishing 12 years that was the first
of november
1981 however just a few months before
everything exploded
sirius black received a letter from none
other than lily potter
dear padfoot thank you thank you for
harry's birthday present
it was his favorite by far one year old
and already zooming along on a toy
broomstick he looks so pleased with
himself
i'm enclosing a picture so you can see
you know it only rises about two feet
off the ground
but he nearly killed the cat and he
smashed a horrible vase petunia sent me
for christmas
no complaints there of course james
thought it was funny says he's going to
be a great quidditch player but we've
had to pack away all the ornaments
and to make sure we don't take our eyes
off him when he gets going we had a very
quiet birthday tea
just us an old batilda who has always
been sweet to us and who dotes on harry
we were so sorry you couldn't come but
the order's got to come first
and harry's not old enough to know it's
his birthday anyway james is getting a
bit frustrated shut up here
he tries not to show it but i can tell
also dumbledore still got his
invisibility cloak
so no chance of little excursions if you
could visit it would cheer him up so
much
wormy was here last weekend i thought he
seemed down but that was probably the
news about mckinnon's
i cried all evening when i heard the
tilde drops in most days
which is a fascinating old thing with
the most amazing stories about
dumbledore
i'm not sure he'd be pleased if he knew
i don't know how much to believe
actually
because it seems incredible that
dumbledore could ever have been friends
with
grindelwald i think her mind's going
personally this letter is a little bit
ominous
because of course we know now that just
a few short months later the potter
family would be destroyed forever
it's written from the perspective of
lily potter sometime in early august
1981 and it's cleared her harry and
james are in hiding
in 1980 sibel trelawny the now hogwarts
civil nation professor
was interviewing for her posting at
hogwarts she had a bad track record
dumbledore gave her a chance because she
was the great-granddaughter of famous
seer
cassandra tralani during her interview a
disappointed and unimpressed dumbledore
began to lose interest
when suddenly sybil entered a trance in
her trance
sibyl spoke of the famous prophecy that
we all know explaining that voldemort
would be defeated it spoke of a boy
that would be born at the end of july
that possessed the power to defeat the
dark lord himself
what dumbledore and sybil did not know
however was that snape
then a death eater was eavesdropping at
the door this meant that the news would
certainly be passed on to voldemort
the entire prophecy is as follows the
one with the power to vanquish the dark
lord approaches
born to those who have thrice to fight
him born as the seventh month dies
and the dark lord will mark him as his
equal but he will have power
the dark lord knows not and either must
die at the end of the other
for neither can live while the other
survives the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord
will be born as the seventh month dies
and that's why the potters were in
hiding
entirely aware of the prophecy and the
fact that their son harry had been born
as the seventh month dies they didn't
really have much choice but to go into
hiding
however they didn't just hide they put
in place all sorts of preventative
measures
to ensure they wouldn't be found most
importantly the fidelious charm
phillies flitwick has a great
description of how it works
an immensely complex spell involving the
magical concealment of a secret
inside a single living soul the
information is hidden
inside the chosen person or secret
keeper and is henceforth impossible to
find
unless of course the secret keeper
chooses to divulge it
as long as the secret keeper refused to
speak you know who could search the
village where lily and james were
staying for years
and never find them not even if he had
his nose pressed against their sitting
room window
the secret keeper that was chosen in
this instance was in fact peter
pettigrew
aka wormtail and what i found
particularly ominous
in the letter was lily mentioning that
pettigrew had recently been to visit
wormy was here last weekend i thought he
seemed down but that was probably the
news about the mckinnon's
of course we know now that it was
probably absolutely nothing to do with
the mckinnon's
wemtail was down because he was ashamed
ashamed of the atrocity that he was
about to commit
the truth is peter pettigrew was only
made secret keeper for the potter family
because everyone felt that the likely
choice sirius black
would be targeted though petticrew was
one of the marauders he was always just
a little bit of an outcast
lily and james only made you secret
keeper because i suggested it
i thought it was the perfect plan
voldemort would be sure to come after me
would never dream they'd use a weak
talentless thing like you
it must have been the finest moment of
your miserable life telling voldemort
you could hand him the potters
peter pettigrew eventually revealed his
true colours and in one infamous act of
cowardice and disloyalty
revealed the location of the potter
cottage to voldemort not even a week
after he was made secret keeper
to add insult to injury he then murdered
12 muggles and for him
serious ouch additionally the letter
mentions a little bit about none other
than albus dumbledore's past
dumbledore is a bit of an enigmatic
figure in harry potter
a wise old powerful man that has
accomplished many a feat in his lifetime
however it appears that batilda bagshot
revealed a side of dumbledore to the
potters
that people were previously unaware of
this is a fun little sneak peek into
another side of dumbledore
a side that paints him in a bit of a
different light than we used to
the friend of kellet grindelwald
couldn't be anyway
that's it for today's video do you guys
remember this letter let me know in the
comment section
below until next time it is the unknown
we fear when we look upon death and
darkness
nothing more
[Music]
you